hey let's switch gears and talk about
music a local academy giving up phds and
rock and roll so we're going to try to
get back to mary jane belly as they're
joining us at the performing arts at the
delta academy oh
oh i hear him jay
[Music]
this is pretty good
[Music]
oh my gosh you guys were jamming out you
guys just heard lead instructor paul
shadeja and of course the students
alongside they were jamming out here and
paul you know thank you so much for
joining us brian early this morning as
we know this music production class is
something else not only do you guys have
really cool equipment but this is of
course like no other
yeah we're very proud of the fact that
it's a uh that it actually is a music
conservatory program high school program
not an after-school program a true music
program but in the contemporary sense
which i feel that is you know quite
quite new for our city um
i would like to say that we are still
accepting students for our year one
check out uh
deltaacademylv.com or our own website
rapparrapalv.com
and please check us out there's lots of
information there we have our music tech
courses we have our careers in music
courses contemporary music theory
history of rock and of course our master
class where we learn to play all sorts
of tunes from 50s 60s all the way up to
today i love that we also have you know
another student here this is your second
year lorelei tell me what it is that you
have learned so far and what you are
looking forward to learning
uh so the main thing that i have learned
so far is
truly what it's like to perform at a
real concert instead of those little
school ones
and i'm mainly looking forward to the
more tech side as well
of all the music and whatnot that's
awesome i mean you guys are rocking out
let's close out this segment with you
guys continuing to play because you guys
sound great
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you